ladies and gentlemen the scamming
doesn't stop today we've got yet another
um juicy little scam
coming from the influencer section of
the internet
the biggest scumbag greedy people on
earth who are happy to sell you
out for a few bucks let's take a look at
um
who's going to be doing the scamming
today shall we roll the video
my name's frasier my name is jarvis i'm
tyco i'm ricegum
i'm nikon and i support save the kids
token save the kids token
save the kids token save the kids token
save the kids token
that's right ladies and gentlemen a bep
20 token redistributing wealth
to both holders and charities actually
it turns out to have just redistributed
wealth to the people who got in
on the ground floor aka these guys
now if you're already confused why this
is bad because you see the name you go
hey
save the kids what's wrong with saving
kids hold on let's back up let me
explain
what's going on here this is what's
known as um
a charity token that they're shilling
where
part of the money like a small portion
one percent of the transactions or two
percent
goes to charity they become really
popular to promote because they sound
good
at their heart though most of them are
just once again
you know greedy little ponzi schemes
with nothing really to add
to anything save the kids is supposed to
give money to kids and and save them i
guess
and a huge group of top influencers
jumped on board to promote it these
people include faze clan
um which you may know they're like
fortnite characters
and ricegum who you may know as the
asian jake paul
he's famous for his hit single god
church drop merchant is selling like a
god truck
but that's not all even instagram model
summer ray got involved all these people
promoted this charity coin right before
launch
the price pumped they got out they they
deleted their tweets
suddenly out of nowhere they said hey my
manager called i can't do this
they backed out of this project like a
homer simpson meme and they ran away
leaving their fans holding the bag and
listen
i know what you're saying steven who
cares
just let a influence or scam their fans
you know you know aren't you sick of
trying to hold these people accountable
when we all know nothing's gonna be done
about this
but of course we know the answer is i'll
never stop
okay because i'm devoted to holding
these people
as accountable as as humanly possible
which i think
the bare amount of accountability here
is just that people know what you did
because right now the tweet deletion
is going on like crazy i mean these
people have scrubbed
these tweets from the internet most of
them i'm here to archive them
for you so you at least know what
happened so let's go to the board
and talk about it ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
i'm your host scott fuzzilla and today
yes
we're talking about influencers which i
know is everyone's favorite subject
right
we've got to hold these people
accountable aren't you sick of it dude
don't they have enough money
bring down the board here okay so this
is the save the kids
token website by the way love that name
it makes you sound like
there's no way it could be a scam it's
for the kids guys but honestly we all
should have known something was up
when they said it's a token
redistributing
wealth because the question is of course
to who i
like to say very bluntly our mission is
to redistribute
wealth a lot of people bristle at that
phrase that is in fact
the phrase we need to use i mean maybe
call me crazy
in hindsight it was a bad idea to trust
the guy who flexes from a yellow lambo
to know a lot about crypto or maybe the
the fortnite boys here don't know
tokenomics that well that's also
a possibility but nonetheless they
promoted it to their fans
anyways in a series of now deleted
tweets but that are archived on the
website itself
phase k says i'm extremely excited to
announce that i'm an ambassador for a
project that's coming
very soon they want to donate over 1
million dollars to charity
in 30 days launch is on june 5th another
promotion to his fans
same guy 4 000 members in the telegram
and the name hasn't even been
released no other project has done this
faze nikken says i'm so excited to be an
ambassador for a new altcoin that's
going
live saturday they're donating to
charity it's something i truly believe
can make change faze tico sort of the
brains of the operation
then jumps in announcement i'm the third
ambassador for new charity altcoin with
phase kane
phase nikken we're going to be making a
difference and changing some lives
don't worry guys you change lives all
right and then we have uh
ricegum ayo guys super excited to be an
ambassador for
save the kids bsc this is going to be
one of the biggest charity coins
ever on the bsc network they hype it up
they get people really excited you got
faze jarvis
getting people really excited they just
finished a boxing match
and the point is they're telling their
fans if you're a fan of me you're gonna
be a fan of this coin
so understandably thousands of people
flood into the telegram chat
they get super excited to jump on this
coin instagram model summer rae also
promoted it let's take a watch
okay guys one more thing i haven't
really gotten into the coin world at all
but my first venture is i'm just now a
ambassador for this coin it's called
save the kids
um it's a charity coin and this month
alone
we're going to give a million dollars to
charities
wow so they're going to be giving a
million dollars away they're hyping up
this uh launch so the day of
what happens it goes to the moon right
guys well
no the the the answer is the first day
it pumps and immediately it
dumps all the way to negative 90
i mean people completely lost their
shirts on this thing
and pretty soon people start accusing
rice gum
and these people of getting in on the
pre-sale
and dumping their bags which if you're
not familiar with crypto basically means
getting in right here selling right here
that's that's the general idea
but honestly it's really hard to prove
if somebody sold off immediately or not
you need their
actual wallet address what we know is
that
all the whales in the coin sold off
immediately
and why would ricegum the king of the
lambos
do anything if he's not actually
involved in some of the project
and so after the coin dumps and their
followers start to lose tons of money
with one of them saying that they're
down
50 percent in two minutes after launch
what do they do well these brave
influencers who got their fans
into this they peace out they delete all
their posts
and basically pretend like it never
happened actually that isn't quite
accurate some of them deleted their
posts like rice gum i believe some of
them
like phase k jarvis some of these guys
left it up
but the point is actually the same which
is they all promised to be ambassadors
of this token and whenever it's time to
actually promote it
now that it's dumped and your followers
have gone in and the value is completely
tanked
they're nowhere to be found now the
question is why would these influencers
stop promoting this coin
maybe it's because according to them
their managers took their tweets down so
apparently the excuse for why they had
to abandon the project
is because they had difficult managers
faze had difficult managers
uh summer ray had a very difficult
manager
you know guys it's just tough when these
influencers they get out of these tokens
and and they're managers guys it's fine
to promote the coin
pre-launch but once it goes live and
fails
and they all abandon guys it's the
manager's calling
so on the way up when everyone's making
money in the pre-sale when they're
promoting some garbage coin
hey it's fine but when the coin
disastrously tanks and all their fans
are screwed
rather than stick with the project they
go oops all right my manager's calling
i'm sorry i'm gonna have to cut this
in this interview short but look now
what right like like what can we learn
from this well two things
number one never trust influencers never
ever especially about
anything related to finance police
number two and this goes out to the
influencers if you wouldn't
chill a penny stock some worthless penny
stock
don't shill worthless crypto
with you know anonymous founders etc
because a common defense of these people
that i always hear is like
hey maybe they were well intentioned hey
maybe they didn't know it was going to
be a scam whatever
but that's the thing if you weren't sure
that it wasn't gonna be a scam
why promote it to your followers like
you wouldn't go push some
pink sheet trash why are you gonna push
some random crypto that started a day
ago
like that doesn't make any sense at all
this is why i'm not buying the whole
like well they didn't know
influencer excuse because people come to
me all the time listen
now that we're like the crypto call out
channel here
people come to me and they go hey steven
like hey man like i'm not doing anything
wrong right like i may have promoted
this or i may have promoted like that's
not too bad right
i i get the sense that what they're
trying to get at is hey
can i push this like like what if it
fails like am i gonna be a scam if it
fails
and my message to these people is like
if you're
thinking that this project could has a
reasonable chance of failing
don't show it to your audience like if
you want to gamble
that's fine don't go push that on your
audience these
influencers are just ridiculous man
they're pushing
trash on you guys when it fails they cut
their losses and run and pretend it
never happened
everyone else may have let you get away
with it everyone else may have given you
a pass
for shilling these trash coins to your
followers but not me baby
i'm gonna call you out every single time
anyway that's basically it i don't know
do your own research
be smarter don't get involved with
stupid influencers
and thanks for
[Music]
you took my watching away
you said that it was safe but i'm robbed
and i don't feel okay
[Music]
i trusted you you said that it was all
right
[Music]
oh but now i'm broke and my wallet